MICHAEL WINDSOR:
Hello, everyone.
Am I live?
I am live.
You can hear me.
Excellent.
Welcome to our talk.
My name is Michael Windsor.
I am a product
manager at Google.
I've been here for
about three years.
Since I got here my focus has
been around G Suite, developer
platform and tools.
I've been leading the
team towards getting this.
Really happy to be here.
And here with me is Geva.
You have our email
addresses there.
Just so you know,
my email address
is spelled geva@google.com.
It works really well.
It's good.
GEVA RECHAV: Hi, I'm Geva.
I'm product manager
for App Maker.
I've been at Google
for five years now.
And I've worked on
Google Maps recently.
I'm from Israel.
And did a few startups
and worked in VCs
before I joined Google.
And anyone who is in
the room with us today,
we assume that you're either
an IT developer or a business
analyst working on a line of.
Business or you may be a
partner supporting companies
in their business processes.
There are probably some CDOs
and CIOs, and CSOs here.
We believe all of you have
business workflow challenges
in your companies and you're
looking for quick and efficient
ways to deal with them.
So we're here today to talk
to you about App Maker.
This is our solution for
internal business apps, which
you can develop using low-code.
And the key benefits of this
product are that it's fast,
you can do your data binding
UI design very quickly.
It's integrated so that
you can like pretty much
have any data source
with your app,
and use any Google
service with it.
And it's compliant.
So it's based on Google
Drive and G Suite.
And so that means that your
domain security rules apply,
and the data doesn't
leave your domain.
MICHAEL WINDSOR:
So I want to start
by talking a bit about how
we came to this place, how
we came to develop App Maker.
And it starts really
with you, the customers.
When we started having
conversation when I first
started at Google, talking
to customers about what
they were trying to do.
As they would move
towards Google
they had all these
different problems
that they had previously
solved in various ways.
Some good, some bad.
And they wanted a way to
build these solutions running
on top of G Suite.
And these are problems
that are not well met
by the major SaaS products.
If you think about
whether it's just
G Suite, or Salesforce,
or Net Suite,
or Marketo, all these
different things, right?
These are great things.
They solve things very well.
But they tend to sort of
normalize and commoditize
the problem domain
that you're working in.
And you have less flexibility.
And so if you think about
the main silos of software
you have your line
of business software.
That's how we make the donuts.
Operational software which
is how we pay for the donuts
or get them paid.
And then productivity.
The gaps in between
those spaces are
where businesses
try to automate,
try to connect things,
and make it work well,
whether it's order
fulfillment, or event planning.
Whether it's, you
know, approvals
for various internal business
work processes, or scheduling,
you know, like
planning helpers where
I need to have a queue
of people can come in
and book office hours.
These are things
that today are solved
by horribly manual
processes involving
lots of emails, documents.
We've all seen the
spreadsheet from hell, right?
Every business has somebody
who's basically unfireable
because they manage
that spreadsheet that
is used for some incredibly
important crazy process.
And everyone's here is
like, chuckling like,
oh, yeah, I know that guy.
And you know, when we see
people trying to solve this
sometimes they go off and they
use various SaaS solutions
out there.
They self serve.
And that creates
admin headaches.
They've got new silos of data,
new clouds of compliance.
So admins are very
worried about all
these unauthorized
solutions coming in there.
So this is the context in
which we came, and we really
want to start solving
those problems.
GEVA RECHAV: I want to
help set the picture here
with one example.
A few years ago at
Google, our recruiters
from the HR department reached
out to the IT department.
We called this the corp eng.
And they were facing a problem
of really wildly increasing
volume of candidates.
We were starting to see
thousands of candidates
at Google every month.
Each one of those
was interviewed
by at least one interviewer.
So we were getting a lot
of textual feedbacks being
piled up.
And it was taking a long time.
And it was really difficult
to assess these feedbacks.
So we were looking into some
kind of manageable solution
that would also let the
recruiters calibrate
the different candidates
across different skill sets,
and be able to get back to the
candidates in a timely manner.
So we looked into
how we can build
an app that will do this
quickly and efficiently.
In addition to this I ask
from the HR department
there were different areas,
different parts of Google
that had their own requests
and special processes
that they wanted to
tackle in a good way.
So they were reaching
out to the IT department
continuously with more and
more app building requests.
And the IT department
was also looking
to automate their own
internal processes,
as I believe many of you
look to automate processes
like dashboards to track a lot
of projects that are ongoing.
So the IT department started
building business apps
to deal with their own workflow.
We realized that we need a good
solution for low-code business
app development at Google
so that we could actually
make our software engineers very
efficient doing these custom
apps and spending the majority
of their time developing
the hard technical
problems that we have.
And also, at the same
time, to empower a lot
of other different
people in the company
that have some level
of coding affinity
or like to actually
go ahead and develop
business apps on their own were
getting very little assistance.
So this was really
taking off very well.
And we were starting to see
a lot of internal apps being
built. And there were
lots of areas that were
getting addressed by App Maker.
As you can see, in
the last three years
we've got to almost 400 apps.
And they have currently 100s,
and some of them even thousands
of Googlers using
them, sometimes daily.
A lot of the people
inside the company
are not even always aware
that they're actually
using an app that was
built with app maker, which
is a great success.
And the majority
of these apps was
built by non software engineers,
or with little software
engineering help.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: And
people outside of corp eng.
So cop eng was not tasked
with taking these things on.
Other teams said, we're
going to build this.
And corp eng said, that's OK
by us, which was a huge win.
GEVA RECHAV: And
so the major point
that we want you
to take away here
is that we were seeing a
very impressive transition
and lowering of the bar for
building custom business apps
by moving the
development of these apps
from software engineers
in the IT department
solely to also seeing
them, you know,
being built by a lot of other
different people outside of IT.
MICHAEL WINDSOR:
So let's talk a bit
about why this is such
a point of pain, right?
Why is it hard to
build these apps?
Why is IT not prioritizing
these applications?
And how can we do this better?
So earlier on I talked
about how, you know,
it's line of business,
operational, and productivity.
Well, if you're a
business planner, when
you think about your
IT spend and how you're
going to prioritize
your resources,
it's on the things
that absolutely
matter to the business.
Line of business first,
operation second,
and productivity, and
everything else, and the gaps,
well, they come second.
If there's a way for
humans to solve a problem
you're going to prioritize
expensive software development
elsewhere.
And that is aggravated,
or exacerbated,
by the fact that the
stakeholders are coming
to you with problems
that they understand
from their perspective.
But they're not
software developers.
They're not product managers.
So their ability to articulate a
plan about what we should build
is just not their
problem domain.
It's not what they do.
They are sales specialist.
They are HR specialists.
They're all these other things.
They're not product managers.
So everybody knows in IT knows
when somebody from accounting
comes to me and says, I got this
really important thing I need
you to build, they have no
idea what they're talking about
and you dread actually
trying to build it, right?
And that's a big problem.
And then it's just
the basic fact
of building an application
is not a trivial exercise.
We know how to do it.
There's a well-defined
pattern we use.
Different frameworks, different
app systems, you know,
hosting environments,
and all of these things.
But there's a lot of
work to stand that up.
And then of course, keeping
it up, maintaining the code,
and operationalizing it, keeping
it running on an ongoing basis,
is non-trivial.
So these are all things
that get in the way
of trying to do that.
And then, finally, you've got
your policy and admin people
telling you apps have to
conform to certain basic things.
We don't want rogue apps, rogue
IT, rogue data everywhere.
So this is just a
big problem we really
need to take on
and solve, in terms
of how we build these apps.
So we're really
excited about being
able to bring App
Maker into this space,
because App Maker
is part of G Suite.
It means every G Suite
for Business customer
has access to App Maker.
These applications run on--
and this was a
critical requirement,
our customers were
very clear-- they're
run on G Suite infrastructure.
So they leverage all
of the security, all
of the compliance, all
of the scalability,
all the operational
support, SRE,
as we call it, Site Reliability,
all of that is built in.
You have as many
applications as you want.
The pricing of
the application is
tied into the G Suite
for Business thing.
It's paid for.
All right?
So it scales to the size
of your organization.
But you can have as many
applications as you want.
You can have as many
databases, as you want, right?
You don't have to worry
about that problem.
So again, from an admin,
and compliance, and policy,
point of view, the cost
is built in to your G
Suite for Business license.
It scales to organization.
And the whole goal is to extend,
to enhance your productivity
suites, whether it's G Suite
apps, or third party apps that
are part of your portfolio
to integrate them
and to create a more
solution oriented space
for your business users.
Is this is my slide?
GEVA RECHAV: Yeah,
so now we are going
to invite Chris to show you
hands on how to build an App
Maker app right here and now.
CHRISTIAN SCHALK: Hey guys.
So let me just go ahead and
switch over to my screen.
All right.
So can you guy see it?
So once they switch
over the demo--
OK.
Great.
So hello.
How are you guys doing?
My name is Chris,
or Christian Schalk.
So I've actually been
working with App Maker
for a number of years.
Probably more years
than I care to admit.
And so a lot of the apps
that Geva was referring to,
I actually you know, was
helping build out a lot of those
solutions internally at Google.
So I'm happy to
at least give you,
hopefully, a quick demo of
what App Maker looks like.
So let me just switch over into
how to build an application.
So what I'm going
to do is just create
an application based
off of a spreadsheet
in just a matter of minutes.
So in this case,
what we're looking at
is the App Maker environment.
And I'm going to create
a new data model.
Also, I should point out this
is based off of a template.
So if you ever want to get
started with App Maker,
you actually have a whole
series of different template
applications.
Some of them are
quite sophisticated.
But in this case, I just use
like a simple starter app,
which gives us like the
menu, header, and so forth.
So that's what we're
looking at right here.
So let's create a
backend data model.
So essentially this is
like the backend database
for our application.
It's going to utilize
Google Drive Table, which
is a new database that
you get for free whenever
you build in App Maker.
And I'm going to create a model.
In this case it's like
a series of stores,
like a global registry of stores
that we need to set up a way
to do on site inspections.
And so in this case I'm going to
first click on Import the field
where I can go ahead and base
the App Maker data model off
of this spreadsheet.
So I happen to have my
spreadsheet accessible
in the Google Drive
Picker window.
And I once I select
it, it will actually
scan a little bit of the
data so I can visually
confirm that, yep,
that's the data that I
want to base my new model of.
It will then go through
it and, essentially,
guess at what are the
data types for my fields.
And I'll click Create.
And now we have
a new data model.
Now, if I wanted to, I could
go in and further customize
the fields, like adding
validation and such.
And while I'm at it I'm going
to go ahead and actually
import the data as well.
So let's just go ahead
and select the store.
And since I have the
global store sheet handy
it'll keep that ready to go.
And that will start
the connection now
to the actual spreadsheet and
start pulling that data over.
And I can even return
back to the main page.
And while that import is
done-- oh there we go.
It's already finished.
Now I can switch over and
start building the UI.
Now, the first thing that
you typically want to do
is set up like a default
data source for your UI.
So in this case, I'm just
going to point it to the stores
directly.
So that makes data
binding a lot easier.
So I can start to drag and drop
widgets, which in this case
I just drag a form.
And so the idea being that I
can build forms, tables, really
any UI construct very easily
by dragging and dropping
the widgets.
In this case it's like
a composite widget.
It's going to build me
an entire insert form.
And so for this one I
want to keep it simple.
I just want a couple of fields.
I want the location.
And I want the inspection date.
And we'll leave it at as that.
I'll click Finish.
So there we go.
We've got a form that
got generated for me.
If I want to
customize it further
I could take out some
fields or whatever.
And now I'm going to
drag and drop a table.
And the table is going
to essentially iterate
through all the records.
And for this one I'm just
going to select location.
I'll add a rating.
So like when you do
a site inspection
you can put that data in there.
And of course, the date.
And for this one I'm going
to have editable fields.
And I click Next.
And Finish that off.
So now we have a design
time view of our table.
Let me just kind
of size it a bit.
So as you can see with the
App Maker visual environment,
it's quite easy to
customize the UI as needed.
And I'm going to
add another widget.
So I just do like a quick
search on the palette.
And we happen to have
a Google map widget.
I'll just drop
that onto the page.
In this case, I'm just
going to kind of resize it
a bit so that it will stretch
over to the size of the top two
forms.
And this is where it gets,
fun because I can data
bind the widget over here
in the property editor.
And I pop it open
into binding mode.
And I just set the location.
So now, whenever I'm pointing
to a record it will show that.
Now, there's another
customization
that I'm going to do.
Right now I just
have a text field
that got generated for me.
But I'm going to spice it up a
bit with a star rating widget.
So I drag and drop the
star rating widget,
stick it right
next to the rating,
and you can blow
away the rating.
And then you can guess what
my next step is, right?
I need to set the value to
a data bound value coming
from my backend database.
And I set it to rating.
And so that's
basically it for now.
I'm going to go ahead
and click Preview.
So in this sense,
what it's doing,
it's taking what I've done,
what I've designed visually,
compiling that
into an App Script,
and sent over to the
App Script run time.
So now we are
looking at this data
right here where I can
click through, and maybe
sort the data, or even directly
change some of the data.
And of course if I wanted
to add some data here,
like maybe our Paris location.
And maybe select
a particular date.
I love the
accessibility features.
I can do all that very easily.
And so now I have a new record.
So we have a store in
Paris that we go inspect.
All right so let's go back
and add a little bit more
functionality to
the application.
So in this case, I'm going to
add a little bit of scripting.
And the idea being that
whenever I insert a new record
I might want to send an email
to the person that's actually,
you know, inserting
or requesting
a new store inspection.
And so how can I do that?
Well, I happen to have a
little bit of code here.
which I'll go through it
a little bit more closely.
But basically this
is a bit of code
that's just using
App Script directly
to then send an email to
the person who's doing that.
So now all I have to do
is create a new script.
So we have a nice script
generation wizard.
And it will even generate
some sample code as well.
And so this script is going
to be running on the server.
So it's running App Script.
So I click Create.
And there's a little
bit of example code
that you can learn from.
In this case I just paste that
new function that I created.
And this is a function
called Notify.
And I want this to be
called whenever I create
a new record in my database.
So I can go back to my data
model, click on Events,
and then on the On
Create Event I could just
call the function directly.
And here I can specify
the actual record,
which contains the location as
well as the inspection date.
Those are just data objects.
So that's going to fire off that
whenever I create a new record.
So let's go ahead and
hit preview again.
Also I should check
my email here.
So there's no e-mails
in the queue, for now.
I don't want to
turn off my WiFi.
All right.
So let's create
a new inspection.
Michael, Geva, any location?
GEVA RECHAV: We're
going to Helsinki.
CHRISTIAN SCHALK: Helsinki?
OK.
GEVA RECHAV: Yup.
CHRISTIAN SCHALK:
Helsinki it is.
GEVA RECHAV: I hear it's
really nice right now.
CHRISTIAN SCHALK: Helsinki
and what date do we want.
Some time--
GEVA RECHAV: I'd
like to go there
in the cold, dark
times of winter.
CHRISTIAN SCHALK:
How does June, sound?
OK.
Yeah.
All right.
There it goes.
So we're all set.
Now, let's go check our email
and see if we got a message.
Surprise, Surprise.
I have an inspection alert.
It says, greetings.
Your store at the Helsinki
location will be inspected.
Blah, blah, blah.
So that's basically it.
It hopefully gives
you an idea of how
you can work with App Maker
starting with a spreadsheet.
Drag and drop some
widgets, put a little bit
of coding in there, and
we're just literally
scratching the surface.
So if you have a chance,
please come to our demo grounds
on the third floor
by [? Schoening. ?]
We'll show you a whole
bunch more stuff as well.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: So I want
to take a moment here.
[APPLAUSE]
That's awesome.
Very nice.
And I wasn't timing it.
I really should.
Like that was five, maybe
eight minutes to build an app.
Now, that's not an
app that, you know,
is everything everybody
could possibly imagine.
But it's an app that
can be used right away.
And it's like literally a
personification of Agile
where this is what you
asked me for, show me
what you need next, show
me what you used, right?
You can put in
analytics into your app.
You can start gathering data.
You can start knowing
what your customers need.
And the investment of time
there was trivial, right?
And you can easily imagine
that person who knows nothing
about product development
sitting down next to someone
like Chris and saying, I
need something to do this.
And it starts with a
spreadsheet and turns
into a usable application
where now it's
managed, auditable,
trackable, everything,
and you can start integrating
into other workflows.
And then all of
the things that you
want to start having happening
are no longer like, oh,
god I'm back in that
spreadsheet from hell
trying to write a macro.
So these are just some
of the other customers
that we've worked with early
on in the stage of sort
of building out App Maker.
They've been our
partners for a long time
in helping us flesh
out the product,
build real life use cases.
I just want to call them out.
In particular, State of
Colorado, Sanmina, me
and the State of Wyoming.
Is Flint here?
Flint, are you here?
I can't see him.
You're all dark bodies in a
gray background right now.
But Flint is actually was the
CIO of the State of Wyoming.
They got in and
got in really early
and did some great things.
And he's actually loved it so
much he now works at Google.
So that worked out
really well for us.
No, it doesn't work out.
If you all build App
Maker applications
I can't hire every
single one of you.
I'm not allowed to do that.
So I want to talk a little
about one of our other customers
who've also been a
tremendous partner with us.
They got involved
relatively early, as well.
Ocado is an online
retailer in the UK.
They have a lot of employees.
They have a lot of
technology investment.
There's a big engineering
department there.
But like I said, those
engineers are very focused
on their core line of
business requirements.
As the business
is growing they're
solving business problems.
But they have a lot of people
doing things, including
training, going to
conferences like this,
taking on training
activities and so forth.
And this was literally
just an entire mess
of emails, manual processes,
multiple spreadsheets.
I'm sure paper was
involved at some point.
It was an incredibly
taxing process.
It was inefficient.
Nobody knew what was going on.
If you wanted to find out what
conferences had been approved
to go to or were
standard process
there was no way to know.
You just had to know
the right person.
And no management around
budget or approvals.
It was just like,
Fred said it was OK.
I'm going.
They felt that app maker
was a perfect opportunity
to kind of automate
that process for them.
And so they were able to sit
down and start building out
an application in
very little time.
And so they actually now
have a deployed to production
application being used
by hundreds of employees
to go to conferences,
to manage the process,
to workflow around it,
to set up training.
Now, this is where
things get really good.
So Chris built that application
in about five minutes.
They built their training
management tool and conference
attendant management
tool in 30 hours.
Not 30 calendar hours.
30 engineering hours.
It was spread out over a
course of about a few weeks.
In the thirty hours they built
and deployed that application.
Now, is that
application perfect?
I don't know.
I never used it.
I'm sure it's amazing.
But 30 hours is really
amazing how quickly
you can get to
something being used.
And that's a big deal.
GEVA RECHAV: So
you've heard about--
CHRISTIAN SCHALK: Sorry, I
forgot about Paul's quote.
Paul is a CTO.
I actually got to
meet him last night.
Is Paul here by any chance?
Another dark gray
cloud of people.
They get it, right?
Paul understood that
they could go and take
on problems they could
never have taken on before.
And I want as I have
said this several times.
I want to say it again.
App Maker is not about
building the apps
that you're building today,
where you have a stack,
where you have a production
environment, where
you're focused on line
of business operations.
It's about taking on all those
apps that you desperately want
to have in your business
but simply could never
bother to take on because
the cost was too high,
the viability was
not obvious or clear.
These are tremendous
opportunities
for your business.
And you have a huge pent up
need that you may not even
be talking about.
And this is what
App Maker's about.
And they got it.
They were all over that.
Sorry, Geva.
GEVA RECHAV: You've heard
about a few customer stories.
Seen how to build
an app very quickly.
I want to tell you
where we are today
with other hundreds of
customers that we have.
So we started rolling this out
externally about a year ago.
And we had over
30 large customers
that we were helping
build their first apps,
and iterating with them, and
seeing a lot of the problems
that our product had, and fixed
all those before we launched
last November to our
early adopter program.
This program is available
to every G Suite business
customer with an application.
And we now have
hundreds of customers
that are building hundreds of
applications using the product.
The general billed e-launch is
planned for later this year.
And by that time we'll have
passed the audit process
that all Google new products go.
So we will be compliant with
international standards.
And we are also working on great
features to add to the product
before we launch it as an
automatic service in G Suite,
like part of all the other
core services that we
have in G Suite today.
And if you're wondering
how you can actually
get into the Early adopter
program this is very simple.
We have a website where
you can enter your details.
Preferably get your
admin to do it,
because this is the
person we are looking
to approve this application.
So if somebody
else in the company
does that we will
get back to you
and ask for the admin to do it.
gsuite.google.com/appmaker.
And that starts the
process rolling.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: All right.
So I'm going to talk
a little bit about--
I think we've told
you why we got here,
how the customers wanted it,
our own internal problems Chris,
gave a great demo.
Sort of set you up for how
you're going to follow up.
What I want to do now is
a little bit of a dive,
in terms of like why these
things are important,
and sort of, you know,
send you just a first pass
at the different features
and capabilities that
are built into App Maker
and why they're interesting.
So as you saw from Chris's
demo, it's a visual tool.
Right there on the screen.
Cloud based.
Fire up any editor, any
browser, anywhere you want,
and you're up and running
and getting things done.
Drag and drop for UI.
Again, you know,
there are snap tools.
There are guide tools.
There are various layout
things that are built in there.
There's a lot of ease to go
customize the user experience.
And again, you want these
applications to look nice.
They don't necessarily have to
be a user experience nirvana,
but you want it to look nice.
Material design is built in.
If you want to have
different themes and looks,
you can do that as well.
And everything is
HTML, JavaScript, CSS,
standards based.
It's a very standards
based product.
So if you want to go
beyond what we've done,
you want to customize the
experience, for first level,
and just within our editor,
all the terms and concepts
will be familiar to you.
But you can then dive in
deeper and start customizing
the HTML, the CSS directly.
And even writing client
side code in JavaScript
to automate and build
out a richer front end
that goes beyond what we
build into our widgets.
And that's really powerful.
And we've seen some
amazing applications.
One of the internal
applications we
have takes advantage of
D3, the data visualization
tool, and just amazing things.
All data bound to the app
maker data behind the scenes.
So standards based, sort
of runtime and application
frameworks.
Data modeling, another
big thing, right?
The data's just a
general challenge.
Standing up data.
Keeping it available.
Managing the lifecycle the data.
Managing the access to the
data are all challenges
that people have to deal with.
We make that very easy
it's all point and click.
And you saw how Chris did it.
He started from a
spreadsheet, right?
And you know that
most of your apps
are going to start from
that spreadsheet from hell.
Boom.
The data's there.
And then, yeah, you can
go off and you can do
full relational data modeling.
You can have all kinds
of events and triggers
hanging off the data.
And you can build
custom data models.
So you can write JavaScript code
to create your own custom data
model for an arbitrary
data source that you want.
And we're going to keep
extending that, Geva
sort of hinted at it, around
connectivity to other data
sources, because we
know, all right, it's
all very well to
talk about your data
in terms of this application.
You want to integrate
this across the space
to the rest of your applications
as part of your business.
You know, Chris, again,
showed you that sort
of page full of samples.
I want to talk about
that for a second,
because it's not
just sample code.
We actually have a growing
library of what I'm calling,
ready to use applications.
So these are applications
where we didn't just
build something that
looks nice, or it's
a sample that shows
you how to use
this feature or that feature.
This is a turnkey application.
You get it as source code.
You, you know, provision it
and deploy it using App Maker
and use it as is.
And the application
itself has an admin model
where you can go on.
And then the admin can set it
up and customize the experience
of the application
to put, you know,
your business name,
and your icons,
and photos of logos
you'd like, and customize
various preferences
for the application.
It's a SaaS product
that you run and operate
on top of our infrastructure.
And we have a growing
number of those applications
available today.
And we're going to
keep adding to them.
So one of them today
we have is essentially
a clone of our own
internal people directory,
cause it keys off of
the directory services
features of G Suite, and
provides a nice directory
service view into the thing.
And then we have
other apps as well.
Workflow, and so forth.
And this is a key part
of our business strategy.
And we're going to keep
building out these apps.
I feel like I'm at
the Academy Awards
now where I'm getting
the music telling
me to go the next slide,
and the timing like that.
So you've just
totally thrown me off.
It's perfect.
So it's not just about
building an app that
lives in its own silo.
It is about integration
to other services.
It's about connecting to your
various parts of your business.
So first of all, within
App Script, anybody
who has used App Script
knows you have great access
to G Suite API.
But you also have great access
to other Google Cloud Platform
APIs.
And that list will just
keep getting longer,
and longer, and longer, as we
build those integrations in.
We're also building in
features in the future
towards other
services to make it
easy to take the same
sort of Auth magic.
Anybody here ever had to
write OAuth code on purpose?
All right.
Anybody want to do it again?
Right.
So we've built the
OAuth code into-- we
do the OAuth management for
you for all the Google services
and G Suite services.
What we're going to do is
we're going to go past that
and start working with
third party services
as well to get you
having that ease of use
to talk to
authenticated services.
It's a big deal.
This is just the icon soup
page, or the NASCAR page,
if you will, of various
sort of services.
Does anybody know what
the one in the middle is?
Must be an Ads or
something like that.
Is it?
Is it an ad thing?
AdSense.
I knew it was something
really vital and important
to our business.
All right, we'll
keep going here.
So just a quick overview
of the overall architecture
of how things are put together.
This is obviously a beautifully
abstract architecture
that bears no resemblance
to how things are built
and how the sausage is made.
But it's actually
important to understand
how we think about
the problem and how
deployments come together.
So at the top of
this, of course,
is the app maker editor.
That's the experience that
you saw Chris demoing.
It is the IDE.
You can edit source code.
You can build out.
You guys are going to get
these slides and the video.
So you'll get better visuals
of these than your pictures,
I'm guessing.
But you know, feel free.
And that application maintains
and manages the source code
of the application, manages
revisions of the application,
manages access
and collaboration,
is fully collaborative,
real-time collaborative.
So you can have multiple people
work in that environment.
That application, that when
Chris hits Preview or Publish
to go off and deploy
the application
is generating an
Apps Script project.
And that App Script project
is pushed onto the App Script
execution environment.
And now runs using App Script.
Now, this is not
the same App Script
that you might have
become familiar with.
It is a massively enhanced
version of App Script.
And that's now available to all
G Suite for Business Customers
with increased capacity,
better performance,
increased connectivity, various
services, more API quota
and throughput.
So we're really beefing up the
runtime to make App Maker fly.
As I've mentioned
before, we've also
extended what we're
doing within App Script
to make various things possible.
So obviously all
the Google services,
those are familiar,
and like that.
Drive Tables is the built in
storage module for App Maker.
It stores data in its
own private data store.
It's highly performant.
It's not meant to scale
to giant data sets.
So please don't think
this is a cheap way
to get BigQuery going
in your little world.
And we'll talk about
BigQuery in a second.
But it is exactly what you need
for 90% of your applications.
And when you feel like
your needs have changed
or you want to interop
with other systems data,
as well, right?
You can switch to
using Cloud SQL.
And then you'll also
be able to switch
to postgreSQL, or MySQL,
and then other data sources,
as well.
So that's a list of
expanding data connectors
that we're going to build out.
And then those same
data connector things
will also work for talking to
SaaS services that are not,
strictly speaking, a database,
but maybe like Salesforce,
or something like that where you
want to get to enterprise data
and build the data
into your application.
Before you-- no, I was
going to do something else.
Nope.
I've already forgot
what I was going to do.
So another brief call
out to State of Wyoming,
because it really illustrates
how things came together.
So the State of Wyoming
has a great IT department.
They've been building out
things on G Suite for a while.
They've done App Script,
and various things.
They have a team that is
responsible for, essentially,
security of their
software environment.
And they have a set
of tools that they
use to track and detect,
you know, phishing
attacks, and various things.
They leverage G Suite's
built in services
but they have a bunch of
other products as well.
And they wanted to
kind of pull together
a 360 dashboard of all the
things that could happen.
This has been a
longstanding wish of theirs
but they could never
really pull it together.
Again, with App Maker they sat
down and said, we can do this.
And I want to talk
about this picture
here because this
is quite literally--
the guy with the hat,
he's the engineer, right?
And the other people
there are the people
who are sitting there thinking
about the business problem.
They are the stakeholders here.
They are not engineers.
They're software developers.
And this picture is
obviously a little bit
staged but it is actually
how things happened.
They sat down and said, what we
want is this information here.
We want to track
these things here.
We're going to pull these
things together there.
And the engineer was able
to do this on the fly.
And in a matter of days
they had something working.
In a matter of weeks they
had something deployed.
And they are now actively
tracking and building out
this application as a way
to track their security
events across the
organization, how to respond,
how to have a
workflow around them,
so when something
happens it's not just,
hey, something seems bad.
There's a whole process
that kicks off around that.
So really great story
for how you can build out
applications and
compress that cycle.
Where the stakeholders, the
engineering get to market,
get to usage,
happens much faster.
So you learn what you
need to know faster.
And you spend less
risk, less time,
and less effort getting there.
GEVA RECHAV: We want
all of you to be
able to focus on
your business needs
and be able to spec what kind
of problems you need to solve.
And we want to
help you identify,
what are the best candidates
in your companies to actually
build App Maker apps around.
So we want to share some
of the areas where we've
seen a lot of hairiness
and business workflows
that require you know,
better use and more
productive workflows.
So the first one, which
we've already mentioned here
several times is sheets.
Sheets, especially
very large ones.
Especially the ones that have
more than a handful of people
updating them on
the regular basis,
usually hide some
kind of process
that's being done internally,
and hasn't been fleshed out
to the extreme.
And so a lot of times
there are errors happening.
Several times people are
updating the wrong cells.
They're taking decisions
based on information
that's maybe not accurate.
And in general, you know, it's
not a very good experience
to start diving into a sheet and
look for the information that
is especially critical to you.
So this is an area where taking
App Maker, spec'ing your UI,
binding it to this data
source, to the sheet,
and building the
process in this UI,
could really change
things for the better.
Another area that we've seen
is around administrative tasks.
And that relates to bulk
and recurring operations
with other G Suite
core services.
Especially Calendar and Gmail.
If we look, for example, at the
store inspection application
that we saw, this is something
that, without the application,
requires scheduling tens
of events across the year,
attaching documents to
those calendar invites.
There must be errors if
you want to update those,
you again have to find
the right calendar entry,
and update that one.
Same way if you're sending
updates, or reporters,
or if you're requesting
information from customers,
vendors, partners.
You're generating the same kind
of Gmail blasts every week,
or 10 days, or months.
And this is another
area where you
could automate and have a much
more fluid experience with App
Maker.
The third area that we have
seen where people could benefit
from building an app is
where you use BigQuery a lot,
where you're calling APIs.
You're already using
scripting in extensive ways
so that means that you've
probably already tackled
some complex
workflows, but in order
to maintain those workflows,
change them, make the UI nicer
it would be much better to
use App Maker to tackle those.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: And I
want to talk a little
about Big Query for a second,
cause that was the thing I
forgot to talk about.
We've actually seen an
increasingly common pattern.
You know, BigQuery is not free.
And people want to have various
ways into the BigQuery data.
And what people are
starting to build
is App Maker applications
that are essentially
this front end to your
BigQuery experience, where
it helps the user
construct the query,
figure out what
they're trying to do,
connect the various pieces
they want, runs the BigQuery,
and then caches the results in
a local data store, which then
can be used for
multiple traversals,
and sort of exploring,
and exports, and whatever.
So you essentially use it
as a cache for the output
of a BigQuery response.
You might choose not to rerun
the query over and over again,
because the user's just
sitting there poking around
at the data.
It's been tremendously
effective.
It's a great
pattern to build on.
We're going to start building
out samples in the same way.
Thanks.
GEVA RECHAV: So this is
a great point in time
to hear from two
people that we have
in the audience with us
today, about their experience
and how they tackled
problems that they
face at their companies.
First I'd like to call up
Mario Zuniga from Sanmina.
MARIO ZUNIGA: Hello, everyone.
Can you hear me?
OK.
So I've been in Sanmina for
10 years, leading enterprise
applications development teams.
And lately, in the
last three years,
I'm responsible for
the digital work place
team that is responsible for
all the collaboration platforms.
And Google is one of our
main pieces in our portfolio.
So when we heard about
App Maker early last year
we got very interested,
because it fits very well,
our class centric strategy.
We want to do all
cloud first whenever we
are looking for applications.
And the fact that the
application is in the Cloud,
and is following the same
kind of the structure,
and using a single technology,
it's a great thing for us.
So as these guys
mentioned, there's
always the need for local
applications for specific use
cases.
We, as an enterprise
team, can not
resolve all the
business problems,
because we have too much.
And the big thing is timing.
So instead of weeks, we can
develop our applications
in hours.
Also the fact that we
have all the applications
in a central place.
We also reduced the rework.
So if the plant in Brazil
has developed the application
to resolve to be the
business problem, a.
And there is a
plant in Australia
that is looking for the same
kind of problem resolution,
they can reuse that same
application and avoid rework.
So for us, going
forward, we want
to invest much more in
App Maker development.
Element The use case
that we see today
are basically for simple
workflows, and paper reduction.
A manufacturing
company we have lots
of inspections, and checklists,
and many things that App Maker
is just a great fit.
MICHAEL WINDSOR:
Thank you very much.
GEVA RECHAV: Thank you.
Next is James Ferreira
from Ignite Synergy.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: Hey, everyone.
So Ignite synergy is a business.
We were a software development
company on App Script.
I've written to O'Reilley
books on App Script.
So when we heard
about App Maker we
were super excited that it
was a new platform built
on top of App Script.
And so we've provided
a product that I
wanted to announce today.
It's called App
Maker University.
And what we're doing
is providing training
for App Maker, and online
training, online videos,
and also in person, and
bootcamps, and things
like that.
And I wanted to mention
a couple of the clients
that we're working with that
we're helping train them.
Some of you are here
in the audience.
So just screamed out.
GEVA RECHAV: Yeah, there we go.
JAME FERREIRA: The we go.
Over there.
Awesome.
So one of the companies
we're working with is Quora.
And they had, of
course, a spreadsheet
based application that
was doing scheduling
and things like that.
And it just isn't scalable.
It's really hard to manage.
They're constantly duplicating
it and having to rebuild it.
And so we suggested, well,
why don't we try App Maker?
So we're moving that
project over to App Maker.
We're also working with
a company called MSA.
They're a large
construction company.
And they have built their
entire business process
in spreadsheets.
And I actually helped
do some of that
by writing App Scripts to make
those spreadsheets connect
to things and services,
and work well.
And when we saw App
Maker, we were like, wow,
you could rebuild your whole
entire business process
in App Maker.
And so that's exactly
what they're doing.
And they're really
excited to be doing that.
So lots of great stuff going on.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: James,
tell us a little bit
about App Maker University, in
terms of what the goal is here.
JAME FERREIRA: Yeah, so the
goal of App Maker University
is, you know, we realized
that it's a brand new product.
There's really no
books written on it,
or anything else like that.
There's not a lot
of areas to find out
how you can get started.
So we've got a lot of
getting started videos,
a lot of explanations
about how you
use the different widgets,
what they actually
do, how you set them up, how
you go about creating apps.
And we're providing
a boot camp, as well,
so that you can go from
no knowledge at all
to completed applications,
and have a really high level
ability to be able to create
those for your businesses.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: So we
found during our, sort of,
trusted tester program
that we had people
come in to boot camps with us.
And I think James, basically
took all our ideas,
and stole them, and turned
that into a product.
And I applaud you for it sir.
JAME FERREIRA: It's
something like that.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: Frankly,
it's exactly what we want.
There's only so many of us who
can talk to so many of you.
Extending the reach
is really critical.
I think that if your
company is starting
to engage in thinking about
building in App Maker,
dive in by all means.
But accelerate the process
by bringing in people who've
been doing this for a while.
They know the pitfalls.
They know the ways to go do it.
Best practices.
It's a great story.
So I'm actually really
glad you're starting.
That was a key part of
our long term strategy.
JAME FERREIRA: Great.
Thank you.
GEVA RECHAV: Thank you.
GEVA RECHAV: As we head towards
the end of our talk we want
to mention what's
next for the product,
and what's next for you in the
audience, and your company's.
So you've seen a
lot of functionality
that we've presented here today.
And we want to tell
you, what are the three
main themes that we are focusing
on before general availability
later this year.
One area where we
see a lot of demand
is to connect App
Maker, the platform,
to a lot of data
sources that you already
have in your companies and you
would benefit from building
business apps around those.
So we are actually already
developing some ways
to connect these
external third party data
sources to our platform.
And we believe that
this would really
ease the migration of many non-G
Suite environments to G Suite.
The second theme space
that we're working on
is to make the product
even faster and easier.
So we are going to provide
more templates and ready
to use apps.
We're also looking
to have modules
that are part of apps that
you could use and actually
build your own apps in
a faster and easier way.
So you can mix and match
functionalities that
are common to several apps.
And that would make everything
even easier, more useful,
and faster.
Third theme is to
create an ecosystem.
So we've heard from
Mario, for example,
that in large companies,
different departments,
different plants tend
to have similar needs.
And they may, you know,
grassroots develop
the same kind of
apps multiple times.
So if we have a good
way to engage, like,
a broad audience inside
the company with what's
being developed by other
people, that can be very useful.
And we are looking
at the best way
to let you share your
applications with others
inside the company.
And also with the broader
app maker community.
So any company that
is using app maker
could benefit from an app that
was built by another company.
So if you're willing to share
your code and help others
that will be great.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: We've
seen a lot of interest
in like, not the
actual app itself, but
various components and pieces.
So the packaging solutions
that will make up App Maker
are going to be
part of that story.
We're really interested
in moving that direction.
GEVA RECHAV: And what's
next for all of you, like,
as you head out of this
room in a few minutes?
So you can learn more
about the product
by looking at our tutorials
on the Google Developer site.
If you're already in our
early adopter program,
or you would like to see some
of the questions and issues
that our users are
already bringing,
you can join the App
Maker users group
and see what's being posted
and discussed over there.
There are also
code labs that you
can access through the
group and actually, you
know, take some learning
exercise for yourself
and see how that goes.
And very relevant, we have
a showcase at Muscone West,
on level 3.
So we would really
like to see all of you
and let you try, hands on,
playing with the product
yourself right now.
And also meeting a lot
of our engineering team
that's on site, and
can, you know, get
into much deeper details
with any one of you.
So we'll be there until the
conference on Friday afternoon.
And remember anyone who
wants to apply, and register,
and be part of our early
adopter program, it's very easy.
You're either a G Suite
Business customer already.
Or if you're considering to,
that's a good decision to make.
And then you can apply,
and get into the program.
Michael.
MICHAEL WINDSOR: All right.
So we've covered
a lot of material.
Gonna start bringing
it together.
We really hope you've
enjoyed this talk.
Simple call to action.
Go to the showcase today.
Try App Maker.
Join the AP.
Start building
great business apps.
Low-code, faster development
cycles, internal applications,
scale with the size
of your organization.
I want to thank in particular
the App Maker engineering team.
They have been working on
this, literally, for years.
It's been a tremendous project.
And we're really excited
to bring this to market.
I want to thank our
partners, as well.
Both those who have
been up here today,
but also people who have
been with us for a long time,
the trusted tester.
To Geva and Chris for
doing a great presentation.
And thank you to you
for coming today.
We've really enjoyed this talk.
Hope you did, as well.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]